نحن الان داخل مدينه مروي بالولايه
الشماليه مرت اكثر من اثنتين وسبعين ساعه
على دخول قوات الدعم السريع الى هذه
المنطقه من دون تنسيق او ترتيب مع القوات
المسلحه المواطنون في هذه المدينه يعيشون
حاله من الخوف والتوتر ازاء وجود هذه
القوات داخل مدينه مروي الاوضاع الان في
مدينه مروه مستقره تماما والحمد لله كويسه
خالص خالص ما في اي حاجه ولو في تحافظات
بسيطه اصلا المواطن بتاع مروي بيرفض بس
التدخل الاجنبي المقصد بالاجنبي الدائين
من برا الحدود المنطقه دي عامله منطقه ما
بتحتاج لاي
مشاكل في الشارع ما عندنا عشان يجينا
الدعم السريع ولجنه
ما حصل شفته في السوق متدخلين في مشاكل
ولا في حاجه والله احنا من الجزيره
شغالين بوتاجاز لكن ما شاء الله بلد رخيه
وبلد هاديه وبلد فيها سرقه لا فيها مشاكل
لا فيها بلد ما شاء الله اما هنا فهذه هي
قاعده مروي العملياتيه الجويه العسكريه
التي تقع في شمال السودان وتتبع للقوات
المسلحه السودانيه هذه القاعده وصلت اليها
قبل اثنتين وسبعين ساعه قوات من الدعم
السريع تقدر قوامها باكثر من مئه مركبه
عسكريه في هذه المنطقه من خلفي تمركزت هذه
القوات التي تتبع للدعم السريع ولكن قبلا
وصلت هذه القوات التي تتابعونها الان الى
هذه المنطقه تتمركز لتمنع الانتشار
والتمركز الجديد لقوات الدعم السريع الذي
وصلت الى هذه المنطقه بحسب بيان اخير
للجيش هذه القاعده العسكريه الجويه هي
قاعده مروي تقدر مساحتها باكثر من 18
كيلومتر خلال والسنوات الماضيه مجرد فيها
عديد التمارين والتدريبات العسكريه التي
ضمت الجيش السوداني ممثلا في القوات
الجويه الى جانب القوات الجويه السعوديه
والمصريه وعدد من القوات الاقليميه حتى
هذه اللحظه التي نتحدث فيها ما زالت قوات
الدعم السريع موجوده هنا في الخلف في هذه
القاعده وهنالك مجهودات ومبادرات مبزوله
من اجل النزع فتيل الازمه واخراج قوات
الدعم السريع من خارج قاعده مروي الجويه
العسكريه نزار من امام قاعده مروي
العسكريه لقناتي العربيه والحدث لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات